lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
intentar resolver la ecuación
diferencial la derivada de con respecto
a x es igual a x porque pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la solución general
bien lo primero que suelo pensar al ver
una ecuación diferencial es si es
separable o no lo es
recuerda cuando digo separable me
refiero a que puedo pasar todas las yes
y day es de un lado de la ecuación y del
otro todas las x y de x en este caso
puedes hacerlo si trabajamos nuestras
diferenciales como variables algebraicas
lo cual es completamente válido en
ecuaciones diferenciales como están
podemos multiplicar de ambos lados por
de x y podemos dividir de ambos lados
entre james entonces multiplica desde
ambos lados por 1 entre james por lo
tanto estas de x se cancelarán y estas
10 se cancelarán y me quedara que 1
entre james
de james es igual a x de x del otro lado
ahora tomaremos la integral indefinida
de ambos lados de la ecuación cual es la
anti derivada de 1 entre g
bueno visto de forma general esto será
el lugar y tu natural del valor absoluto
de james y esto será igual al anti
derivada de x que es x cuadrada entre
dos más una constante de integración
solo estoy poniendo una sed de un lado
que equivale las dos constantes de
integración y ahora sí esta es mi
solución general pero si queremos la
solución en términos de james podemos
tomar una función exponencial de ambos
lados
otra forma de pensarlo es que si esto es
una igualdad entonces elevado al
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
jane es igual a elevado a la x cuadrada
entre dos más ahora en que nos ayuda a
esto la razón es que del lado izquierdo
me queda el elevado al lugar y natural
del valor absoluto de 10 es decir voy a
elevar a m a la potencia a la que tengo
que elevar a efe para obtener el valor
absoluto de bien por lo tanto el lado
izquierdo de esta ecuación se simplifica
simple
al valor absoluto del ahora del lado
derecho podemos usar las leyes de los
exponentes así que diremos que esto va a
ser igual a el elevado a la equis
cuadrada entre 2 que multiplican a
elevado en la cem pero el elevado la c
podemos pensarla como cualquier otra
constante es más fácil pensarla como una
constante c de tal manera que ahora
podemos reescribir todo esto como se
esta nueva se que multiplica a en
elevado a la x cuadrada entre 2 no te
preocupes
sólo use las propiedades de los
exponentes en elevado a la suma de dos
cosas es igual a en elevado al primer
sumando por el elevado al segundo
sumando y después me dije elevado a una
constante bueno es simplemente otra
constante por ello le puse el nombre de
c azul y entonces me quedé con c azul x
y elevado a la equis cuadrada entre 2
sin embargo seguimos teniendo este signo
del valor absoluto pero por suerte
podemos decir que esto es igual a james
igual a más menos se sea azul por el
elevado a la equis cuadrada entre 2
ahora como todavía no sabemos esta
constante es positiva o negativa
simplemente es una sea arbitraria una
constante nueva entonces podemos asumir
este + - como una nueva c la cual será
se roja así que podemos decir que es
igual a 0 ham por el elevado a la equis
cuadrada entre 2 y esta es mi solución
general a la ecuación diferencial
separable inicial hemos acabado hasta
pronto